la patagonie au sud de l'argentine
deux fois et demie la france
à peine un million d'habitants
l'une des dernières terres vierges de la
planète
[Musique]
partout des moutons encore des moutons
un trésor sur pattes une toison d'or la
laine de patagonie est réputée comme
l'une des meilleures au monde
[Musique]
à 12000 kilomètres de là le quartier des
grands magasins à paris une enseigne
célèbre pour son slogan benetton et son
united colours les couleurs unies
le métissage l'ouverture sur le monde
une marque de fabrique
des pubs qui ont fait le tour du monde
[Musique]
dans les boutiques du groupe comme
principal argument de vente la qualité
des étoffes le tissu décliné sous toutes
ses formes
parmi les plus recherchés la laine de
patagonie
[Musique]
parce qu'on n'est jamais aussi bien
servi que par soi même benetton a acheté
en argentine un immense domaine le
groupe est devenu du même coup le
premier propriétaire terrien du pays
mais la région est aussi le territoire
ancestral d'une communauté indienne
l'ema push
et les descendants des premiers
habitants de la patagonie ne voit pas la
présence du groupe italien d'un très bon
oeil
[Musique]
nous les indiens vous savez ici on est
complètement entouré par benetton et
profitent de nous et c'est terrible
parce qu'on est des pauvres gens
que se passe-t-il donc en patagonie à
quel prix benetton produit-il sa fameuse
laine
voyage au pays des caoutchoucs
pour atteindre les premiers grands
espaces de la patagonie de buenos aires
la capitale il faut compter deux heures
et demie de vol
d'abord à l'infini la pampa puis
surgissent les montagnes la cordillère
des andes qui culmine à plus de 6000
mètres d'altitude
à l'atterrissage direction plein sud
pour finir ce long voyage une seule
route la numéro 40
il y avait vu un sommet
plus de 2000 kilomètres d'asphalté
jusqu'à la terre de feu le bout du monde
de l'hémisphère sud la dernière zone
habitée avant l'antarctique
la nature à l'état brut comme elle
existe de moins en moins
[Musique]
d heures de 4,4 et nous arrivons à
destination l'estancia de l'est les
quais l'un des domaines de l'immense
propriété achetée par benetton en 1997
près d'un million d'hectares
l'équivalent de la moitié de la belgique
ici le patron c'est viviane youmzain
béret cheveux roux il est d'origine
galloise et fier de l'être ses ancêtres
ont débarqué il ya près d'un siècle
nous on est à côté des moutons si vous
voulez nous rejoindre
bon ok on se voit là bas
la mène et miniac la radio pour
communiquer entre eux oui
parce que la propriété trop grande
exactement donc ici tous nos véhicules
sont équipés du même système de
communication on a équipé aussi les
maisons de nos employés
comment vous appelez
c'est quoi ton travail au juste on
commence ici à 7h du matin et on passe
nos journées dans les champs
es tu aimes ton travail signifie bien
sûr que je laime c'est pour ça que je
suis ici sinon gens chercheraient un
autre
[Musique]
dans ce troupeau deux mille têtes en
tout dans les stands ya des dizaines de
milliers de moutons
[Musique]
la patagonie une paire idéale pour
l'élevage les grands espaces mais aussi
la météo
[Musique]
là je regarde la température
ce matin il faisait un degré
et là maintenant il fait 19 degrés
les conditions ici sont vraiment idéales
pour
pour élever les moutons bien sûr ses
terres là sont idéales il pleut un peu
mais pas trop juste ce qu'il faut
l'idéal
[Applaudissements]
dévia news accorde une attention toute
particulière à son usine à champions ce
qui se fait de mieux en matière
d'élevage produits de savants croisement
des bêtes de concours qui raflent tous
les prix
salut ricardo comment ça va
très bien monsieur c'est bon je vous les
ai préparé tout est prêt oui oui
on peut aller les voir ricardo s'occupe
exclusivement de ses moutons qui font la
réputation de l'estancia
vous voyez ce bélier il a un arbre
généalogique qui remonte à plus de 50
ans
celui là il est vraiment spécial c'est
le fils d'un bélier qu'on a acheté en
australie
et en fait son père est le seul à avoir
réussi à gagner tous les concours en
australie
et ici nous l'utilisons comme
reproducteur
sa caractéristique est d'avoir une laine
d'une excellente qualité une très belle
couleur un très uniforme à ses propres
et une très grande quantité de l'aisne
et bien sûr une naine très fines comme
tout ce que nous produisons
et on peut faire combien de polo avec
cette laine
combien de paulos
c'est une question un peu technique
mais nous on estime qu un bélier comme
ça doit produire plus ou moins 18 kg
s'est imposé face à ricardo je te 18 kg
de laine
c'est clair que cette laine est celle
qui a le plus de valeur
je ne sais pas si c'est la meilleure
mais en tout cas c'est la plus chère
[Musique]
oui
une fois par an les moutons ont droit à
la tonte
cinq minutes chrono par animal
chaque année les stands siaap produit
450 tonnes de laine
[Musique]
cette pelote a souffert pendant l'hiver
sûrement à cause de l'humidité
et ça produit comme un léger défaut
la laine est un peu abîmée mais ça reste
une très bonne qualité
l'avait conditionné cette laine sera
ensuite expédiée en italie
mission accomplie pour l'animal les
ateliers benetton feront le reste
tout votre propriété clôturé comme ça
avec des barbelés oui et pourquoi
c'est une manière de délimiter notre
propriété le fil de fer
on a beaucoup de kilomètres de barbelés
ici
convient
combien je ne sais pas plusieurs
milliers de kilomètres
les milliers de kilomètres de barbelés
ont bouleversé la vie de la patagonie
finis les grands espaces et la liberté
de mouvement
les bergers ma bouche de la région sont
les premiers touchés comme dans un bon
vieux western le fil de fer contre les
indiens
segundo par exemple satair est
entièrement encerclée par benetton alors
ils s'adaptent qu'il fait chaud bonjour
bonjour il est où votre troupeau mon
troupeau ses limites dans le champ là
bas
où ça chez benetton
talât
pendant que ses bêtes broutent l'herbe
de benetton segundo nous invite chez lui
enfants petits enfants ils sont dix à
vivre ici
on vit tous ici dans cette maison des
pics ma famille est venue s'installer
ici
cette séquence à
nos ancêtres ils sont arrivés ici en
[Musique]
mais quand l'un de ses fils de fer sont
à benetton et vous voyez il arrive
jusque là bas
tout au fond
tout est clôturée tout est à benetton
regarde mes petites filles elles
arrivent on a eu de la chance mais vous
êtes trompé de terrain où vous les
mettez toujours ici non non je mets
toujours là comme j'en ai déjà dit on
vit ici depuis toujours on a toujours
mis nos bêtes la
[Musique]
franchir les barbelés de benetton
segundo est obligé de le faire tous les
jours pour aller chercher ses bêtes
être berger en patagonie cela ressemble
presque à une course d'obstacles
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
c'est un gros problème pour nous parce
que je ne sais pas si vous avez vu le
petit terrain que j'ai comment voulez
vous qu'on élève suffisamment d'animaux
pour s'en sortir
pour nous ça a changé énormément notre
manière d'élever nos bêtes parce qu'ici
moi je m'en souviens bien il n'y avait
pas si fils barbelés et mon père avait
plus de 400 moutons il avait des chevaux
des vaches plus de 30 vaches et avec les
chauves on s'occupait bien de notre
bétail
là on ne peut plus avec les barbelés
les barbelés un obstacle pour les
chevaux sûrement le pire pour un gars au
chaud
c'est difficile d'avoir un voisin comme
benetton c'est ça ouais c'est difficile
parce que quand on marche on n'est
jamais libre sur cette terre
tu marches toujours en pensant ce que
pourrai te dire les autorités elles
peuvent te prendre tu es bête on nous
accuse d'aller là on n'a pas le droit
d'aller selon
en fait c'est eux qui nous font du tort
en barrant l'accès nos animaux
mon grand père me disait si tu marches
sur cette pierre elle est à toi
parce que toi tu es né ici en argentine
c'est comme ça et aussi
[Musique]
là bas ils installent des barbelés à
pointe et avec ça il ya beaucoup qui se
passe mais pourquoi le mettre ce type de
barbelés simplement pour empêcher nos
bêtes de passer mais bon les animaux
font deux trois passages par ci par là
alors leur laine s'enroule autour du
barbelé après elle peut se passer
tu vois comment elle mettre leur laine
on dirait qu'elles le font exprès
benetton est venu ici pour la qualité de
cette laine oui bien sûr c'est pour ça
que l aqua en particulier ni totti cette
laine
elle ressemble beaucoup à la soirée
c'est en plus de ça
elle est très ferme
c'est comme ça qu'on les reconnaît ben
est ancrée benetton connaissait cette
laine avant de s'installer ici
bien sûr oui parce que avant qu'il
n'arrive on vendait toute notre
production pour le marché italien
c'est pour ça qu'il savait qu'ici il y a
de très bons produits
[Musique]
à
on
pourquoi alors se compliquer la vie
pourquoi finalement ne pas travailler
directement pour les stands sia
segundo qui retrouve son fils
travaillait pour l'ancien propriétaire
mais quand benetton a racheté le domaine
il a préféré quitter la compagnie
quand tu cette arrivée ici on avait un
très bon salaire et nous aussi on était
contents mais ça n'a duré que deux mois
après c'était fini tout ça donc
nous avons décidé qu'il fallait quitter
l'estancia et qu'il fallait s'en sortir
par nos propres moyens
et notre temps là bas
[Musique]
moi je connais certains des nôtres qui
continuent de travailler là bas
et souvent ils ont un salaire de misère
un salaire de misère que je connais bien
parce que moi aussi j'ai travaillé là
bas quelques temps
et j'ai vu comment nous exploiter le peu
qui nous donnaient
alors après il y a des gens que je
connais qui me disent je viens viens
l'estancia on cherche du monde et moi je
leur dis oui mais pas pour 25 pesos je
ne vais pas me tuer pour ça parce que 25
pesos est rien
[Musique]
25 pesos et 5 euros par jour alors pour
la famille de segundo mieux vaut encore
se frotter aux barbelés de l'estancia et
construire son propre avenir
[Musique]
en argentine benetton ne s'est pas fait
que des amis et pourtant le groupe fait
tout pour être adoptée par la région
un musée consacré à la patagonie a été
créée à l'intérieur du domaine
nous retrouvons viviane yutz pas de
chance son musée est fermé jusqu'à
nouvel ordre et plus personne ne
retrouve la clé
pas le choix nous passons par derrière
cette fois ci le patron de l'estancia
n'est pas seul
karina une responsable de la
communication a fait le voyage depuis
buenos aires pour notre venue on est où
là exactement
ici on est au musée de l'ailé qu'est
la compagnie a voulu faire un musée
là on a une photo de carlo benetton auto
patron oui et vous avez déjà rencontré
la famille benetton en personne oui
monsieur carlo benetton viens souvent
ici trois ou quatre fois par an tous les
deux trois mois
il est là parce que lui il adore la
patagonie
le musée censé retracer l'histoire de la
des abris des flèches des frondes aucun
problème avec la guerre contre l'indien
et la conquête militaire mais malaise
dans la visite guidée aucun signe d'
emma putsch et les ma bouche
par là enfin si en réalité ils viennent
du chili c'est la région d'origine
désarroi quand
ici c'était l'été which he
may au chili c'est désarroi quand on les
appelle aussi les mâts putsch
les mapuches apprécieront il ne serait
donc pas argentin mais chilien au musée
l'histoire des indiens se termine par
leur défaite loi du plus fort les
barbelés font déjà leur apparition
la ruée vers la laine commence fini les
indiens place aux moutons
cette région est très belle il y a
beaucoup d'eau de rivières de lacs mais
pas par qui et c'est grâce aux moutons
qu'on à peupler les zones désertiques
toute la patagonie a été peuplée avec
lui
[Musique]
suite de la visite toujours pour faire
plaisir à la région les bonnes oeuvres
du groupe des bibliothèques des centres
de soins est la dernière réalisation
financée par la compagnie le gymnase de
la petite ville voisine de maiden
l'occasion pour nous de revenir sur le
conflit qui oppose benetton aux indiens
propriété privée contre tradition ma
putsch de monde
on ne comprend rien et franchement on
essaie mais on n'arrive pas à comprendre
nous vivons dans la nation de
l'argentine nous sommes sujets à la loi
argentine à l'aller et
imaginer que moi j'allais au pays de
galles où vivait mes ancêtres et là je
débarque et je dis mon
arrière-arrière-grand-père vivait ici il
avait ses vaches sa maison et moi je
veux construire une maison
qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire ils
m'arrêtent ils vont juger et me mettre
dans un avion et on me renvoie direct en
argentine
ce qui doit se passer ou non
[Musique]
face à benetton il y à une poignée
d'irréductibles
des indiens mapuche partie sur le
sentier de la guerre
il habite à quelques kilomètres de
l'estancia
bienvenue à la communauté santa rosa
[Musique]
sur cette terre vivaient nos grands
parents nos ancêtres
[Musique]
et benetton n'a jamais pensé que leur
sens
leur racine
resterai ici
le monde indigène ne peut pas vivre sans
la terre et ça c'est quelque chose
qu'ils ne comprennent pas ou qu'ils ne
veulent pas comprendre
[Musique]
le monde indigène qui a une culture
millénaire considère la terre comme sa
propre mère alors on ne peut pas vivre
sans mais
les conquistadors venu ici pour prendre
nos richesses et s'en allait
le néo colonisateurs lui peut nous
prendre des choses mais il veut nous
pousser dehors et vers où je ne sais pas
nous ne demandons aucune permission pour
être là ni à benetton ni à la justice
simplement si on demande pardon à notre
terre de l'avoir abandonnée
cela fait maintenant six ans cathy liot
et sa femme rosa s'accroche à ce bout de
patagonie
pas d'électricité pas d'eau mais peu
importe
ce qui compte pour eux c'est la terre
m'a putsch peut dire termeer
[Musique]